nous ouvrons une page culture à présent
le mimo quittera demain soir la ville de
trappes alors le mimos et le musée
mobile
il fait le tour du monde depuis cinq ans
à la rencontre des jeunes dont les
villages et les quartiers de la france
mais aussi de l'europe
l'objectif intervenir à l'âge où les
enfants apprennent à lire écrire compter
pour qu'ils apprennent également à
regarder ressentir et imaginer le musée
itinérant est gratuit il est aménagé
dans un camion il est installé depuis
une semaine sur la placette des
merisiers porté par l'association à des
amis du mur mobile propose une quinzaine
d'oeuvres d'art contemporain créé par
des artistes de renommée mondiale comme
paul mccarthy ou encore james naturel
écoutez ces précisions recueillies par
man rabat et william l on va montrer aux
enfants que voilà l'oeuvre d'art c'est
pas seulement un tableau une sculpture
ça peut prendre la forme d'une vidéo
d'une photographie d'une installation
lumineuse
ils vont être au contact direct des
oeuvres certaines d'entre elles ils vont
être immergées à l'intérieur et donc
l'idée c'est de créer le choc esthétique
chez les enfants de créer du
questionnement est de créer une envie
aussi d'aller plus loin et d'aller voir
d'autres musées ce qui est très
important de dire c'est que les artistes
revendiquent ça ils n'ont pas cherché à
simplifier leurs oeuvres
parce qu'il s'agissait d'enfants il ya
même l'artiste pierre et vick qui a fait
une vidéo pour le mot qui explique que
justement pour lui les enfants sont tout
à fait à même voir coup plus à même que
les adultes de saisir la complexité
d'une oeuvre et qu'ils n'ont justement
pas les a priori les barrières qu'un
adulte peut avoir avec l'arrêt notamment
l'art contemporain